we can't have madmen out there shooting
rockets all over the place
rocket man should have been handled a
long time ago he should have been
handled a long time ago by Clinton I
won't mention the Republicans right by
Obama I can tell you one thing you are
protected okay you are protected
nobody's gonna mess with our people that
was President Trump at a huge rally in
Alabama tonight
let's get reaction so Rocket Man on the
agenda Greg Gutfeld don't mess with
President Trump but it's you know he's a
master at labeling let's face it Rocket
Man is pretty good just couple of
interesting things about this he's he's
in your living room when he's talking to
you there's a it's a contrast between
him and Obama and the old Obama was
erudite academic contemplative Trump is
blunt he's simple and he's direct he's
in your living room talking to you as
though he knows you and it's we we we
it's not I I we we we he's there to
protect you we are here against this
enemy it's it's why he won is what
you're seeing it's it's a very simple
and direct message and it were any
reverse the judgmentalism the UN would
judge us and now he went into there he
went into that place and he judged them
how refreshing is that very refreshing
and Gutfeld makes a point that he's
really as a billionaire real estate
mogul for manhattan assumed this man of
the people mantle where he'd go down to
Alabama and be one with the folks
Kimberly yes because he's authentic in
his own skin he really loves what he's
saying what he's doing how he's doing it
and he conveys that to the crowd he
conveys warmth to the people that he
really cares about them that he wants to
get the job done and then he was very
happy to list the number of
accomplishments because he's gonna take
it you know to himself to do it because
he's not gonna rely on the media to
actually get it out there there were
things that he's done that we actually
remembered that were so far and early in
the administration that people might
have forgotten about he makes the point
about well the rocket man ran wild under
Clinton not going to mention the
Republic
he does have a point
oh gosh we can go farther back I mean
it's been a while that Kim jong-un's
been around or Kim jong-il or their but
so to me canoes here from this speech is
the dog that didn't bark because guess
what you never heard a word a negative
word about the Ayatollah of Alabama Roy
Moore ooh and you know why because it's
not only our saying Ben Carson seems to
have endorsed them but you look at this
Sarah Palin you know what I'm saying
Steve King you can go on Huckabee trills
Sebastian Gorkhas behind him they're all
with Roy Moore does that Judge so does
that make you look at Trump with respect
because these he's not going with those
guys he's going on his own no I think he
feels and he feels that he has got to
have the votes and I think he was really
honest about this when he said he looked
over to big Lewis there that's his name
he looked over to big Luthor and he said
I got your vote on the tax thing that
was the key he needs that vote the only
reason and he was fairly explicit about
this at the beginning of the speech the
only reason he was here tonight and the
only reason he was endorsing strange is
because strange committed to endorsing
Graham Cassidy and this is what he wants
that's why he's here on a Friday night
when he doesn't really want to be there
cuz he has other things to do in
Washington he loves the White House it's
really beautiful despite what the Press
says he thinks about the White House
he'd rather be there looking forward to
the game tomorrow I mean how many people
can start out a speech by telling you
that they don't really want to be there
not that jazz to be there and then keep
you tuned in for an hour and yeah he was
either gonna move to Alabama if he had
lost what it is quickly it's a good
contrast what we're seeing we're seeing
Trump and we're seeing Hillary what he's
doing is a victory tour she's doing a
victimhood tour when you're seeing these
together you go mmm made the right
decision but you know what
then the apology tour wanna me